evacuation of mario paul has now been
suspended i'm joined now by ina dragon
chuck she is ukraine's vice minister for
veteran affairs and joins me now
we aren't saying where she is for
security reasons
ina what is your response to the fact
that these human corridors have had to
be closed virtually as soon as they were
opened
uh you know this green card was one of
the most
sensitive issues to be discussed during
the negotiations and for this moment we
do expect that
all people from uh
temporary occupied territory so those
which are the closest to these
territories uh can be moved to most to
more safety place and that we will be
able to bring medicines and other
humanitarian aid to these regions so for
all ukraine we do expect for this moment
when it will start and when we will see
the results and feel that our people
will feel themselves safety
do you have any idea of the latest
numbers of civilian casualties that
ukraine has suffered
well you know we have just official
information about it for this week
because more than 1.5 million uh people
left ukraine and borders but at the same
time it's very difficult to calculate
the number of internally displaced
people uh i think that near this time we
will understand the final number when
this green corridor will be effectively
active activated
how hard is it staying in ukraine in
these areas where the majority of people
have now left
you know it's difficult to explain in
several sentences because um
from one side we're absolutely highly
motivated and optimistic and we do
believe that we are extremely strong for
this moment not about army but it's
about our nation and our beliefs from
another side absolutely we all are
absolutely exhausted emotionally
exhausted and uh
we are that's why we are united to
support one another uh there is no panic
to be honest if you can see any station
restraints of humanitarian
and you will see there definitely
absolutely passions support kindness and
absolutely there is no any chaos and any
panic so that's the moment which i am
proud most of all our people that even
in such crucial moments we support one
another
and how is morale amongst those who are
civilians but who have decided to fight
listen everybody of us
now is fighting i mean somebody of us is
taking their arms but at the same time
everybody of us feels that we are an
army
and it's
very
clear for my nation for all of us that
it's not something theoretical which is
taking place in our country it's about
the historical moment when we can be the
leaders for all the future nations and
for all our future ukrainians so the
emotional we absolutely
feel ourselves strong and uh
as i said before that it's not about
army only it's not about our doctors on
the touch line on the front front line
it's uh about everybody of us and our
places
ina dragon chuck great to talk to you
ukraine's vice minister for veteran
affairs please stay safe and i hope we
get to speak to you again thank you very
much thank you thank you